thank you Rick and everyone is the real
pleasure to be with you here this
afternoon and and to start by saying a
big thank you to to Yale this actually
has been my privilege my privilege to
have been associated with such a
wonderful institution of learning my
privilege to have been taught by so many
great students my privilege to have been
working with and under the guidance of
President Levin who is an exceptional
leader in my view and someone you should
be very glad you got in charge of
University
he also introduces me or was in a really
kind way yes it's true we had 10 years
of record growth when I was British
Prime Minister I have unfortunately come
to the conclusion subsequently that it
was luck however it did indeed happen
and one of the things that that this
course that we have been which I'm told
you a little bit about this course on
faith and globalization has arisen out
of a particular passion in fact I would
say for me mother the central passion of
my life which is the belief that
religious faith has a as a progressive
an important role to play in the future
but only if people of different faiths
are prepared to live and work together
in peaceful coexistence and I thought
I'd just start by by I'm going to say a
little bit about the course and what
we've learnt and then I I'm going to try
and apply that to some of the practical
political questions that we face today
but just to give you a sort of insight
into how I see the world I can't best do
that to begin with just by a little
travel log of where I've been in the
last a few months in august i attended
for a week the Beijing Olympics which is
this extraordinary spectacle and this
amazing bird's nest stadium and saw the
the emerging power and might and
confidence of China and reflected on how
power is shifting eastwards the whole
time and then and the next month or just
as I was leaving to go to New York that
the news about the collapse of Lehman
Brothers was on the television screen
here's the interesting thing you know i
was watching the popular TV news channel
and not the kind of intellectual one
that small numbers of people watch but
the popular one the large numbers of
people watch and there they were top
story collapse of lehman brothers and I
was kind of reflecting an institution
known in the UK and even heard of a
short time ago suddenly was leading the
popular news program in every corner of
the United Kingdom indeed actually as I
was leaving the house that money to get
into the car to go to the airport there
was a guy who recognized that she
stopped me and said yeah he said who are
these brothers anyway ok if they and
then just a short while after that I was
sitting in a tent in Libya with with
Colonel Gaddafi I've I'd ever Tony
brothers know so there I was out in
Libya well I say a 10 it was actually
about the size of this the size of this
Chapel actually so is it's quite large
but the thing is in fact i'm about to
give you some excellent advice on what
not to say in these circumstances every
so often that a camel's head were kind
of attached to the body will kind of
poke in you know the inside of the 10
and here's what not say if you are asked
have you ever tried camel's milk do not
say no I don't think I ever have
what you say in those circumstances is
yes of course yes many times anywhere I
gave the wrong answer the camel was sort
of taken around the back of the tent or
whatever bit of milking went on whatever
you do quite sure what you do with a
camera but I suppose it must be
something like that and back came to
steaming glasses camel's milk one for me
one for the leader Gaddafi so I take a
little sympathy says no no no is that
how you drink it you drain it the glass
although hours so i drained it and the
thing is that is the fastest moving
stuff you will ever taste yeah so anyway
but but the real point about visit was
that there I was talking with with
Colonel Gaddafi and here's a somebody
whose name was synonymous with terrorism
20 years ago sitting there telling me
that we should wake up that this
terrorist threat was causing trouble all
over his region that people from the
touareg tribe were pouring in over the
border from Algeria and it just came
home to me in each of these three
incidences the power shifting to the
east and the emergence of China the
global economic crisis sitting with
someone who used to be a symbol of
terror talking about the danger of it
and realized that the world in which we
live today is indeed interconnected
interdependent and interrelated and that
has caught major implications of how we
organize human affairs and so at one
level you know to conduct a course here
at Yale about faith and globalization
you might say well
my in fact a lot of people did say why
and I always remember seeing a close
friend of mine who's a a rough and tough
business guy who'd been very successful
in the UK ikot me and the just after I
left office and once we decided to do
the the corset the course at Yale and he
said to me so what you're doing with
your new life in and I said well the
first thing is i'm trying to solve the
Middle East peace process he said oh I
wouldn't try that mate it's hopeless
they all ate each other and he said
what's the second thing and I said well
what I'm trying to do is to bring the
religious face of the world together
it's you what this what's the third
thing I said the third thing is that I
I'd like to do a bit of business he said
you know I thought you've gone
completely crazy there for a min evade
and the reason is very very simple that
I wanted to do this because in my view
the key to understanding the modern
world is that the pressures of it are
pushing people together that is what
globalization does it operates to
obliterate national boundaries it
operates through all sorts of ways
travel communication the internet mass
migration to push people together and if
religious faith becomes a means of
pulling people apart then religious
faith becomes a source of conflict and
division now that is bad for everyone
but for people of religious faith it's
particularly bad because that then means
that faith become synonymous not with
reconciliation and compassion and
justice and all the things that really
true religious face you stand for but
become synonymous with division and
conflict and hatred and sectarianism
so the reason for the course may seem a
one-level intellectual and academic but
in another level is severely practical
because unless we find a way of
reconciling faith and globalization the
world will be a more dangerous place and
actually as I shall argue a less
successful as well as a less just place
we've or at least I got sort of ten
lessons which I'll run through very
quickly which I explained to the the
students on the course today ten things
that have stood out to me from the
discussions we've had on faith in
globalization and it's then the i would
like to echo what Rick said and thanks
of Miroslav Volf who has just been a
wonderful person to work with and you
know after a lifetime in politics is
kind of great to hear intelligent
analysis and and and you know thank you
miroslava before that so here's what I
here are the things that I've the
lessons that I've drawn out of this one
faith matters and it motivates whether
people like it or they don't like it
millions billions of people are
motivated in their lives by religious
faith to faith is not in decline it's in
decline in some places but it's not in
decline worldwide indeed in some parts
of the world it is growing three
religious faith can operate positively
in support for example of the Millennium
Development Goals wonderful work being
done by churches and mosques and Jewish
into relief or it can operate negatively
through fundamentalism and extremism
fourth
globalization is helping create
multi-phase societies if you look at
that the London that my little boy is
growing up in it's a London that's
completely different from the London or
30 years ago and same here in this
country to I've no doubt globalization
is helping create a multi-faith society
and five to work effectively however
globalization needs values like trust
and confidence and openness and justice
and I shall try to argue why that is
true when we come to consider the
practical implications of the economic
crisis six faith is not the only means
but it is an important means of
providing those values if faith is
itself open and not closed and if it is
based on the values of compassion and
help for other people and not on the
basis of exclusionary identity seven
that the goal of faith and possibly
arguably of globalization is human
flourishing and that spiritual capital
is an important part of social capital
in other words the way the faith
community operates within a society and
the spiritual capital derived from it is
an important part of the social capital
that both defines and riches the society
in which we live
eight in an era however of globalization
and multiphase societies creating such
spiritual capital requires not only
tolerance of but respect for people of
other faiths in other words if
globalization is pushing people together
and we are creating multi-faith
societies then the only way that
spiritual capital in rich's society is
if people of different phase not just
tolerate each other but respect each
other nine that the key to respect is
understanding and hence the need to
learn and to educate and ten organized
religion should be supporting this
process and allowing through it the
evolution of faith so that faith can be
indeed a positive constructive and
progressive force in an era of
globalization so the reason why I think
this is such an important area for
modern society and the way that it
functions is that faith matters and
values matter and how those combined in
an era of globalization will critically
define the success the prosperity as
well as the peaceful coexistence of the
society in which we live and that is
because as you could see from my short
travelogue of my experiences that
interaction interrelation
interdependence creates the
circumstances in which if people of
different faiths and cultures cannot
can live together then that becomes a
major source of conflict that then
reacts against the force of
globalization and creates tension
difficulty and even violence now briefly
let me just apply that to practical
politics one of the great things about
this course has been that you actually
do learn from the students I mean you're
right that's why I said you know I was
educated by them rather than educating
me hello I was pleased to see that by
the end of the course when miroslav used
to introduce me as Professor Blair they
stopped laughing but here's the thing
during the course of a of one of our
initial discussions I was arguing the
globalization is essentially a process
that is kind of value free and that
actually whether it works or not
economically doesn't really depend on
values now you can argue that
globalization should have justice going
with it for reasons of justice but not
necessarily for reasons of efficiency
and I was challenged on that and I came
to the conclusion actually the student
was right and i think this global
economic crisis is interesting in a
number of written at different levels
and instantly hit very challenging all
of them but actually if you think about
it it is first and foremost a crisis
that has been brought about in part by
behavior that we wish hadn't taken place
and it is being prolonged by the absence
of confidence that means people are not
sure that they can have faith in the
system I mean faith not as religious
faith that trust in it and therefore I
would argue that as we try and look
forward
to how we put our economies back on a
sound footing for the future values like
trust being able to rely on the other
person's word yeah real asset values
some sense of the long term as well as
short-term profit maximization that
these values actually are the things
that can create confidence and therefore
stability in that system as we move
forward and so hello it will be very
possible to say let's treat this as a
technical economic question you know
what is the technical answer in
regulatory terms to prevent such a
crisis happening again what are the
reasons why the crisis has happened you
can look at it in purely technical terms
but the end product of the global
economic crisis was that even people who
worked alongside themselves each other
for years in financial institutions
could not trust the bond of the other
and I actually think one of the
interesting things there for about the
world of interdependence is that it
cannot function without a strong set of
values underpinning it and I think you
can see that even through this global
economic crisis but if you turn to
foreign policy you see it even more
clearly the security threat we face can
be described in many different ways
personally and sometimes controversially
I see what is happening recently hidden
by and those people who died in that
terrorist attack there and what happens
in other parts of the world all part of
the same security threat
and it's all part of one thing in my
view it's wise i think i said when we
were having the the more open meeting
last time you know people sometimes say
to me should we worry about you know
afghanistan rather than iraq or Pakistan
rather than Iran or and I'm afraid in my
view you have to worry about all of
these things together because they're
all part of the same thing and it's true
that one part of the answer is that
where we're challenged militarily we've
got to be prepared and be able to
respond militarily but it's also true
that it will be the force of ideas
rather than the force of arms that
allows us to succeed and that is why for
example the Middle East peace process if
we were able to secure peace between
Israel and Palestine that would be of
enormous importance a huge symbolic
expression that would militate against
the violence and division and the things
that inspire people to commit acts of
terrorism in the name of God if we were
able as we're trying to do here to
create a space for people of different
faiths to come together and work
together live together peacefully it
would be a powerful demonstration of a
different set of values set alongside
those of exclusion and division
education will become a major component
of foreign policy if we want to be able
to defeat this terrorist threat that now
strikes at virtually every single part
of the world so what I would say is it
this security threat yes is about
military means and security and all the
different issues that dominate the
headlines but it's also critical
about being able to demonstrate support
for values of peaceful coexistence that
can be set us against what is
undoubtedly otherwise a narrative of
division and conflict that unfortunately
has an enormous reach into different
parts of the world now I therefore think
that the consequence of interdependence
in economic Laura policy and in foreign
policy is that unless we have strong
values guiding in both sets of policies
they cannot be effective and for that to
work for that idea if you like of
peaceful coexistence to take root we
need alliances and multilateral
institutions and we need values that are
shared and held in common now the
Alliance's can be very difficult I think
it was Oscar Wilde or orem or Churchill
once said that there's with two nations
divided by a common language that's my
nation and yours but and if you tried in
Europe its can be even more difficult
and forgive me if I've ever told you I
know where I've ever share this one with
you Rick but when I was um I speak a bit
of French I thought I thought I did
speak French quite well
until the particular instant I'm about
to tell you about which is I decided to
do early on my Premiership a live press
conference but early to attending the
last time yeah all my stories yeah and I
was um I did a live press conference
with the French Prime Minister in French
and I was asked by French journalist
whether any policies of the French Prime
Minister desire to emulate I got the
term avoir on V wrong and so instead of
saying and there are many policies of
the French Prime Minister I desire to
emulate I said that I desired the French
Prime Minister many different positions
so
which was difficult to recover from in
the course of that restaurant as I have
to say so it can be hard enough getting
the right alliances within Europe but
truthfully we need Europe and America to
revitalize the transatlantic Alliance
and then we need for both of them to get
the right relationship with China that
is going to be such an important power
and with India and Russia and other of
the emerging powers in the world and
here's the other thing there is no way
that that common value system that we
need to make those alliances successful
is going to happen unless we are clear
that our values are not just about
democracy and freedom but are also about
justice that's why for me Africa is a
moral cause but it's also a cause that
is in our enlightened self-interest that
is why climate change and dealing with
the problems in the environment has to
be done on a basis that is fair and
equitable to the developing as well as
the developed world in other words the
problems that we face today cannot be
sold except on the basis of alliances
that are global and those alliances will
only work if they're on the basis of
values that are also global so come back
to faith and globalization in conclusion
faith can help it's not the sole source
of values there are many people who are
of no faith or anti faith but who have
great values and do great work but the
faith communities can provide a solid
foundation of values and a solid basis
of common endeavor based on those values
but only if faith is not about our
traditions
and it's not about our identity but it's
about our values it's about values of
the common good and compassion and
justice and humankind and our obligation
irrespective of nation race creed
religion color to acknowledge the equal
dignity and equal worth of every
individual before God so I see this
faith and globalization course that I've
had the privilege to be part of this
year as really one of the most important
things we can possibly do for the future
we've got great ambitions now to expand
it to and I will actually have my own
faith foundation I'll have people here
that are based at Yale for next year
we've got really exciting programs for
research for linking up with other
universities but doing major forums and
conferences on the relationship between
business and and faith and good
commercial ethics and faith how this
21st century develops is hard to predict
but one thing for sure is true that
whether it evolves in a way that is
peaceful in a way that in yours to the
prosperity and benefit of all people
depends not simply on impersonal
mechanisms of the market or the desire
for material advancement alone but also
depends if I tily and critically on the
beliefs we have the convictions we hold
dear and the values that we share and if
religious faith
could it at least not be a hindrance to
such a coming together that would be a
great thing but how much better it would
be if you are of religious faith if it
was not merely not a hindrance but it
was an active visible participating
support for creating a world in which
what we want for ourselves we want for
others and are prepared to act in order
to achieve it thank
we have a little bit of time for a
conversation and I have aided here by a
few questions from the audience and a
few of my own maybe we'd start I think
would be interesting to call on your
experience say with Northern Ireland to
get a little to dig a little more deeply
into the question of how can faith or at
least religious tradition play a role in
reconciliation you brought that piece
about I know you would say many people
brought us bad but you've played a key
role in bringing it about by appealing
to religious leaders on both sides of
the divide and I guess my question is a
little bit of a hard question is do you
think that your success really depended
upon appealing to values rooted in faith
as you talk about so eloquently or were
you really dealing with sort of
pragmatic political leaders of
communities that happen to be defined by
two religious you know religious groups
so um and and was it more was it more
that your success depended on the moral
authority those individuals had as
leaders of communities or was it really
rooted in in some sense and deeper
values that emanated from religious
tradition were able to make the appeal
based on religious ideas you can you can
you hear me in this yeah yeah I'd
actually don't think you can divide the
two very easily to be honest and and for
sure in Northern Ireland the were people
of religious faith who really helped and
people of religious faith who really
didn't and but the ones that helped
we're of massive benefit because they're
able they were able to stand up and say
our faith should tell us not to do these
acts of violence but instead should tell
us to reconcile and it is what's really
interesting about this is sometimes
people say to you about a dispute like
Northern Ireland they say they're
actually about the israel-palestine
thing to an extent to they say it's not
religious at all you know it's all
political
and you have to say to them but
unfortunately a lot of the people who
are engaged in i think it is religious
so if you leave aside religion you leave
a side part of the analysis of the
problem and therefore part of the
solution so I found that yeah it was
dramatically important at certain points
and that's why it was great on the
course instead we're to a Catholic and a
and a Protestant Catholic priest
brothers and vicar over as part of the
course which is which is interesting I
think the students found it useful to
write what about in the Middle East here
um you need to hook that everywhere I
think there we go I got it I don't know
I'd one of these poll today right yeah
yeah the to what extent could an appeal
to religious leaders Christian Muslim
and Jewish play a role in the resolution
the Middle East dispute we've talked a
little bit about this in connection with
Jerusalem is there is there is there a
role for that channel as opposed to the
governmental leaders of Palestine and
Israel yeah the razor of course because
I mean the religious leaders can say and
actually we should be trying to live
with one another and get on with one
another and in respect of Jerusalem
there is going to be no solution to
Jerusalem unless it is an open City at
least in terms of faith you know in the
the one of the things that's really and
you might have a standard your answer
the questions but bother you at sure go
ahead because it's just you know after
Prime Minister's Questions I always kind
of
not that you're not a lot polite or at
least so far than they used to be yeah
there's a bit better yeah it's you know
you're not gonna have a solution to
Jerusalem unless it's a place where
people of different faiths can worship
and you know just when I was there a
short time ago you know my office is
just up the road from the old city and
sometimes when you drive past it you see
very obviously Jewish people and very
obviously Muslim people less obviously
but probably kind of Christian tourists
actually when I was there the other day
suddenly some people who are obviously
Hindu I thought from India sort of
drifted by any thought whoa what's going
on but you know it is a it's a place
where people come who are a spiritual
faith so yes it couldn't what's more and
this is the important thing that I was
saying in my point 10 which is for
organized religion to play a positive
part organized religions got to accept
its responsibilities in the Interfaith
world and not kind of say well let the
politicians go and deal with that
actually they should be part of dealing
with it and and I think there are a lot
of enlightened people within organized
religion today who do precisely that
when you answered questions in the House
of Commons and stood did the back
benchers sit or stand
sorry no no no I can I'll get up and
stand with you if you like actually it
wasn't whether they were sitting or
standing really it was the general abuse
with which they would better okay okay
well this is distinctly non-abusive
questioning the let's talk about India
for a minute that the President Bush
famously said that India is a country
with 300 million Muslims and not a
single member of al Qaeda and yet you
know just a week after you and I were in
India this November there was a terrible
terrorist episode how much this is a
question from the audience I mean to
what extent do you believe that the that
attack will really set back the court
the cause of pluralism and religious
toleration within the Indian nation well
here's the thing it's designed to do
that fish you're right so our response
should be to stop that happening yeah I
love it the worst terrorist act in
Northern Ireland in terms of the single
biggest loss of life in one incident
happened actually after the Good Friday
Agreement the OMA bomb in 1998 10 years
ago and there was a point of decision
for the whole of the community and for
the political world the purpose of the
act was to cause hatred was to say to
people this process is hopeless and
therefore together on to give up and I
went out straight away cuz I knew I had
to say this immediately and said this is
the reason to carry on so that these
people do not win so that these people
do not own this process and that is
still absolutely necessary so in India
yes of course the very purpose of this I
mean the random killing particularly you
know and let's be clear again what is
terrible about these events is that even
in their own terms of course they're
they're terrible but actually the
majority people who died will have been
Indians so even if their purpose was to
take it out on Americans or British or
Christians or Jews actually the majority
of people will have will have been
ordinary and is that the purpose of the
the terrorism is to create that conflict
and hatred and to provoke the counter
reaction and that is why it is so
important one that the faith communities
in those circumstances stand up and
proclaim we will not be intimidated into
hating each other on the contrary we
will regard it as a part of our faith to
reach out to the other person and
secondly that they do so in practice but
is it I'm afraid this is a problem the
world over and as that we were saying in
our class earlier today in my view this
terrorism is unfortunately a very
powerful modern weapon in the hands of
an extremist and it is for this reason
that what these groups of terrorists
actually understand now is that they can
obliterate the news with pictures of
carnage and so whatever message you've
got of reconciliation is never going to
be powerful enough to compete with blood
strewn across the the television screen
and they know that and they do that and
it catches the agenda and of course when
it also does because of this very issue
we're talking about of interdependence
of globalization today as opposed to 30
40 years ago an act of violence happens
and it's live on our you know people
followed in Britain in America right
round the world they followed the
unfolding of the the events in Mumbai
live on television and so it has an
immediate impact and that's why they do
it but it's why we've got to be strong
enough to stand up against it and point
that
so here's another question from an
audience member do you think that
terrorist attacks and the one entity
would be an interesting case but but in
general do you think that terrorism
today is more driven by religious
extremism or by economic deprivation and
what would be the best you know
depending on your answer what's the best
approach to counter it will have a very
clear belief that the more prosperous
people are on the better educated and
education certainly i think is as
important as prosperity in this regard
the better educator the more prosperous
the more peaceful that's by basic you
however you cannot say unfortunately
that everyone engaged in this terrorism
is doing it for reasons of economic
deprivation because they know i mean in
the UK the terrorist attacks were were
led by someone who who is a teacher you
can't but isn't there Pat is it a
passion for social justice and the Quran
the correction of economic disparities
that's more at stake than I think it was
religious fanaticism personally I think
it's sometimes wears that suit of
clothes but I don't think it's driven by
that I think it's driven by a narrative
in this case about Islam which is that
the problems of Islam are really as a
result of the complicity of Islamic
leaders with the West that Islam in the
West are set against each other and and
the peaceful coexistence is impossible
um you talked some about in your speech
about values and trust and I think we
all understand that the resolution of
the current economic crisis is going to
require not just quite agree with you
it's not just a matter of technical
economic analysis it's a matter of
restoring confidence confidence of
people in our institutions and our
policies when you were when he did the
panel in Woolsey Hall on sep tember 19th
you without naming names I
two about how does a left party of the
Left win an election in a democracy and
you said that the candidate needs to
move toward the center in order to win
that was about six weeks before the
election and so I asked you first do you
think that Obama took your advice and in
the clothes in the close of the election
moved toward the center and second how
do you think he's doing now we're
clearly the biggest issue in front of
him immediately is going to be resolute
you know reactance the economic crisis
and is he is he positioning himself in
the right way to tackle that important
problem but I think in respect to the
first I think the economic crisis has
did change politics everywhere and I
also think it probably somewhat moved it
left if it moved it in any direction you
know the sense that that suddenly
markets were not so much in fashion
government and the state came back into
fashion so he didn't have to move the
center the issues moved to the left I
think they did a bit yes yeah I mean I
think honestly they did a bit to some
extent at least and also I in Stony I
think the calmness with which he dealt
with the he'll make rice has made a
difference too but but nonetheless I
think what is important in why I think
his choices on the economic side are
also good is that the purpose of
government intervention should actually
be to get the free enterprise system bag
on his feet not to wipe it out in my
view because I think that would be a big
mistake I mean you know people do you
know it's like this is there's no friend
of mine when I was at University we used
to go on demonstrations together which
is you know it's kind of quite
interesting as a leader you know you
remember used to demonstrate against
them and now you get the demonstrations
against you it's the way it happens
but you know so we used to be on serve
when I was very much on that on the left
we used to be gone demonstrations
together and most of the people i was on
demonstrations with on the Left ended up
working for merchant banks and but um
but actually this particular guy he
stayed true all the way through and
abundant and the other day he said I
told you I told you capitalism would
fail and it has so you know it's a great
kind of senses of schadenfreude or in
certain parts of the political system
that you know that they've been waiting
for this all this all this time and and
but I actually think it's a matter of
making the free enterprise system work
better not actually changing it
fundamentally and as for the way that
the president-elect has handled i think
his appointments are given a lot of
confidence to people and his election
was an amazing event around the world
for for sure and i actually think you
you in America should be really really
proud both of the way the election
happened and the fact of the election of
President Elect Obama of the election of
barack obama and also what was an
immensely gracious concession speech by
john mccain and i think the combination
of those two things i think did america
of power good round the world and really
really helped bring out what I think
people in my heart of hearts always knew
which is the best of America there for
the world to see and I think you should
be really proud of it another passion of
yours that in fact you and I share is
the recognition that we need to do
something dramatic to arrest the course
of climate change and yesterday
President Obama appointed perhaps my
personal taste the best of the people
he's appointed yet and Steven Chu a
secretary of energy of brilliant
scientist
who is who's devoted the last ten years
of his life to research leading to
alternative energy technologies and
who's a passionate advocate for global
action on climate change do you do you
think that the current economic crisis
is going to be an impediment to making
progress on climate change or can it be
somehow turned to advantage will it
could be an impediment and it should be
turned to advantage look this is a very
difficult question as all these
questions are in fact I think one of the
things that's really interesting about
the election of barack obama is that I
mean I kind of something of the know of
how it feels to be in the position where
you've got these enormous expectations
and that the problem is the expectations
change but the problems don't you know I
remember shortly being in the New York
shortly after November the fourth and
his victory and there was a woman said
to me isn't it fantastic she said
everything is now possible and I said
like what and she she said everything
and I remember you know myself when i
was elected as prime minister and one of
the curious distinctions with with with
us as we go straight into take office
and I remember going down to the Cabinet
Room straight in after the election and
and there was the cabinet secretary was
the main civil servant and he was a
career 77 we don't have political
appointments in the same way that you do
here and just sort of sitting there in
the Cabinet Room it was my first time in
the Cabinet Room and he just looked to
me said well you've won the election
well done now what and you you know
people with sort of we're a big health
care problem at the time and people kind
of take your hand and say I know you're
going to sort this out for us and I'd
say thank you
and I was kind of yeah but I need a plan
you know I didn't just need this a
fusion of goodwill so I think that for
him on the issue to do with climate
change in the environment what I was
saying to some of my colleagues in
Europe a short time ago is let's stop
asking what he's going to do for us and
ask what we're going to do for him
because he is going if he's going to
lead the way for a global deal he's
going to need to have China and India in
the developing world in it now we've got
to find a fair way to do that but
there's no way he can stand up the
American people and say I'm going to
take really radical action here but you
know I don't know what anyone else is
going to do it's going to be tough so I
actually think well I think the
appointments are good but we need to get
the best global deal we can and I think
it's important American leads in that
way to get it but I also think the
important thing is to set the world on a
new path towards reducing our dependence
on carbon and whatever else we do just
remember this but it will require bold
leadership by Barack evarrim by other
leaders to ok the price of oils fallen
but it's not so very long ago that it
was sky high so let's not forget that
and let's make sure that we use this as
an opportunity to invest in an energy
future that allows us to grow
sustainably and does not carry on in a
way that is unsustainable actually for
our energy security for our living
standards and for the planet so that's
what I would say personally I think we
ought to make it make it impossible
people to forget where the price of gas
was by putting a carbon tax into the
recovery package but that's that's
another that's personal view the
I'll ask perhaps one more question from
the audience and then and then then I'll
as is usually the case i'll throw you a
really tough question at the end this
one's kind of cute actually how do you
think future historians will rate your
tenure as prime minister and your tenure
at Yale I think they'll write one of
them well which is the question mmm do
you mind when people talk about the
judgment and reflection on your time in
office i remind i think was to enliven
the 1970s was asked for his views on the
French Revolution he said it's too early
to tell think it'll be that long but I
don't know i think that the that in the
end you you you make that judgment I
variable a little distance of time
because you've got to see domestically
whether the reform programs you put in
place and work or not and certainly in
foreign policy terms whether the
military engagements Iraq Afghanistan
cosimo sierra leone stand the test of
time or not now undoubtedly we made big
changes as a government but you know the
judgment on all of that put together I
don't know and as for Yale no really I
mean I look whatever your judgment is
about me I have to say
I am I mean I really mean this I've been
amazingly impressed by by you guys and
instantly I hadn't realized that is the
bulldog that's a Yale thing is it it is
it seems to borrow that from the British
I mean the British go bulldog now I
saying to my staff but is there anything
I can say you know that's kind of Gail
like they said it was it girl go
Bulldogs go Bulldogs bulla bulla have it
how about boola boola you could say that
bula-bula you may not want to say that
right anyway but that's why it's
important the different cultures realize
their different systems trying back
together okay here's the hard one what
did you think of the portrayal of tony
blair in the queen
now you know you're not gonna believe
this I've never seen it but I want to
tell you why I've never seen her and I
will share this with with you that when
the movie came out i had my weekly
audience with the Queen I mean the Queen
the Queen so I get a little the room and
as we do every week we sit down opposite
each other and she said to me um there's
a film I said oh yes your majesty and
she said i don't think i'm going to
watch it how about you
so um anyway there it is I should just
one other little thing is to my wife
however did watch it and there is one
thing that I can tell you is inaccurate
and I will now tell you the truth which
is about when I we have the ceremony
kissing hands and I have told you this
hmm know what happens when you go
straight in to become Prime Minister
after you win the elections your
ceremony with the Queen's a ceremony of
kissing hands until you kissed hands
then you're not prime minister right
because the Queen's they had a state you
just had a government I hope you're a
pleb in other words you know your
position is very properly dictated by
the scheme of things so you go in you
have the ceremony kissing hands and
because it's straight after the election
I go along to bucking palace and I'm
really target wee bit up all night we
just won the election and it's all great
and everything but I'm kind of thinking
about government and so on and so forth
and I go and this little ante room just
outside the throne room where the queen
is and there's this guy who's the sort
of one of these Lord Chamberlain types
who sort of standing there very in the
sort of full gear and everything and he
says to me are Mr Blair you're now I'm
about to engage in the ceremony of
kissing hands I want you to understand
however that you don't actually kiss the
Queen's hands you brush them lightly
with your lips
this is what centuries of aristocratic
inbreeding does do they're gonna as you
guys remember so I'm kind of puzzling
about this what does it mean brush what
our when the door was flung open and I
go and I'm so he's sort of
discombobulated by the whole thing and
fatiguing what not that I missed my
footing I trip over the carpet and
instead of brushing her hands my lips I
fall upon her hands with the further I
don't think she has ever experienced
before so that's actually what happened
there you go
then next week stand right here so I'm
going to close with just a few words and
a presentation just in a minute so first
of all I just want to say that we are so
fortunate we're going to have you back
here next year to do the course again
and the year after that you signed on
for three years which is fabulous for
this in universal
but also want to say that I think
everyone in this audience and everyone
that's been exposed to you at Yale
during your time here must share what
what I feel and that is not only you
have marvelous sense of humor which is
obvious but that that this is quite a
remarkable thing about you here here you
are having been Prime Minister leader of
one of the great nations on earth and
yet you have in the way you approach
questions in the way you have approached
this teaching assignment and the way
that you live your life by values an
extraordinary capacity to be open and
inquisitive and willing to learn I mean
it's a marvelous thing to see and we're
an educational institution and naturally
we appreciate it that that it would be
easy for someone of your achievement to
close off to think that you had nothing
but things to do but that all you need
to do was to teach others and impart the
wisdom of your of your experience but in
truth your lifelong learner your model
for all of us and we're deeply grateful
to have you here
and I have the best job in the world
because I get him as a houseguest every
time he comes and as a houseguest I know
I come to appreciate his habits he's
made use of the gym upstairs at the
president's house and so we've got a
little what do you say kit little gear
athletic Barris Yale par finale for
working out in hotel gyms everywhere
you